unwetterchaos in Paderborn
das Tiefdruckgebiet emelinde hat die
Stadt in Nordrhein-Westfalen mit voller
Wucht getroffen
Starkregen und Windböen mit einer
Geschwindigkeit von über 100 Kilometern
pro Stunde
aus einer Gewitterzelle bildete sich
sogar mutmaßlich ein Tornado
diese Amateuraufnahmen zeigen das Ausmaß
stark beschädigte Häuser entwurzelte
Bäume schwere Gegenstände und Dachteile
die durch die Luft geschleudert werden
der Sturm wütete nur ein paar Minuten
durch die Paderborner Innenstadt und
hinterlässt eine Spur der Zerstörung
[Musik]
die Nachrichtenagentur dpa meldet
mehrere Verletzte fast alle Feuerwehren
der Stadt sind im Einsatz